you know the whole marketing campaign
for Deadpool - has been all about
Deadpool vs. cable a story that the fans
were craving well what have you walked
into the movie and sure the first 10
minutes were all this epic to love cable
fighting Deadpool but then all of a
sudden they start pulling back the
cameras and it's just the characters
filming that footage specifically for
the trailer they then wrap the shoot
Deadpool Pat's the actor playing cable
on the back turns to the audience says
gotcha
and the movie was then actually about
something completely different it would
be an entire marketing campaign selling
you on a matchup that is completely
falsified it would be one of the
greatest movie pranks of all time and
honestly it would make it the most epic
Deadpool troll possible and it would
still be poking fun at the movie
industry where scenes are manufactured
specifically for trailers just to
mislead audiences long story short
that's my fantasy choice for what
happens in Deadpool - not gonna happen
but feel free to use it for your third
installment mr. pool
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where the
theories are usually wrong but hex fun
try the YouTube equivalent of a
participation trophy so anyway if you're
still shook from infinity war will then
snap out of it you kiddin snap out
because it's time for Deadpool despite
the huge amount of attention poured on
infinity war over the last couple weeks
Deadpool isn't one that's gonna be left
in the dust I'm not feeling too good
cable I'm not ready to go don't let me
go what today I'm not focused on the
Merc with the mouth instead I want to
focus on a member of his team one
character in particular a character by
the name of Peter W Oh much about this
Cable fella but I guarantee he hasn't
killed as many people as melanoma has
introduced in the final trailer for
Deadpool to this powerless average Joe
has quickly stolen the hearts of many of
the internets I'm here today to tell you
there's more peter than meets the eye I
mean sure he might seem quiet and
unassuming but if I'm reading the
situation right Peter holds a secret
that we're gonna see play out before the
end of Deadpool too so in the words of
the movies trailer
don't call it a kreygasm seriously I
never left in the first place the
YouTube algorithm literally will not let
me stop making videos now if you haven't
been following the trailers or you
somehow haven't gone to the theaters in
the last four months let me bring up the
speed it all started back in February
with the be Deadpool second campaign in
which the Deadpool Twitter account which
famously only followed Hello Kitty
announced that it would now be following
a second random account that retweeted
the hashtag be Deadpool second and
despite everyone expecting a Golden
Girls or Wolverine follow back the
winner did indeed seem to be an account
that came out of nowhere on March 24
Deadpool started to follow at Peter W
underscore 1974 and yet this was far
from a random choice or simply just a
contest winner Peter W wasn't just an
ordinary Twitter account but rather a
comedian named Rob Delaney acting in
character the strange move but still
very Deadpool then just a few weeks ago
it all started to come together when we
finally got a good look at who Peter W
is in act
chin in the movies final trailer last
but not least Peter
any powered when I tell us about I don't
have one I just saw the ad and honestly
this shouldn't have been a surprise to
anyone we should have seen it coming
back in trailer one we actually see a
brief clip of two head shots someone
named bedlam and this other guy named
Peter so as Peter W in this movie is
just some random guy there for the lols
like dopinder and last movie don't be so
quick to judge because Clues seem to be
lining up that Peter W here may actually
have a more important role than simply
comic relief the Deadpool trailers have
been pretty darn direct and revealing
that this is a movie about the x-force
there's Domino who has the ability to
manipulate probability shatter star
Pennywise over here plays the
acid-spitting zeitgeist and bedlam the
guy with a headshot that we saw earlier
an obscure mutant who can mess with
electrical equipment as well as the
brains neural feel which leaves us with
Peter sorry a Peter W to be specific
that last letter there might not seem
all that important to emphasize until
you consider that one of the X forces
most famous leaders is a mutant by the
name of Peter wisdom Peter W now if you
don't have the kind of religious
devotion tonight crawler that felt
Nightcrawler has with religion it can be
forgiven for missing the series of
comics usually centering around Captain
Britain and his cohorts you heard that
right Captain Britain who has the power
to steep tea he's like Captain America
but replacing the Stars and Stripes with
well-loved chest stripes I guess first
introduced on page one of Excalibur
volume 1 issue 86 Peter wisdom starts
his career as a hitman for mi6 a Secret
Intelligence Service for the United
Kingdom
he eventually quits has a run-in with
Magneto and this is where Peter W and
the new Deadpool movie first intersect
you see Peter wisdom becomes the leader
of x-force and starts wearing an
eyepatch because it makes him look cool
which I gotta say opens the door for
Deadpool to make a lot of jokes at the
expense of another certain eyepatch
wearing team leader but a simple name
and a team aren't our only connections
here in the comics source material Peter
was British which may not be the obvious
case for Deadpool
choose Peter W but on Twitter at Peter W
underscore 1974 is following a primary
school in henley-on-thames which if the
name doesn't give it away ain't Brooklyn
it's definitely an odd detail for a
Twitter profile that's dedicated to this
one single character furthermore in an
in character interview with the website
birth movies death Peter mentions that
his father was a detective which
wouldn't you know it is also true of
Peter wisdoms father in the comics who
just so happened to work for Scotland
Yard there are also some more meta clues
that Peter and the trailers might
actually be Peter wisdom if we look at
the trailers it's clear that this kid is
the focal point of the new movie a kid
that Deadpool calls Russell this makes
him almost definitely Russell Collins
aka fire fist a powerful mutant with the
ability to not just control fire like
pyro can manipulate the fire can create
it but to summon fire out of nothing so
what does Russell have to do with Peter
wisdom well nothing directly Papeete
wisdoms mutant power might make him a
good counterbalance you see Pete wisdoms
most famous mutant ability is his hot
knives conjuring fiery blades at his
fingertips to serve as knives or
projectiles he's like a living breathing
thousand-degree knife challenge but
using those hot knives requires that he
also has a source of energy in the
comics Peter summons energy from the Sun
but he also is able to absorb power and
heat from attacks and explosions so if
there were an ideal x-force member to
wrangle an out-of-control Firebug like
Russell someone like Peter who could
absorb their raging energy might be the
perfect person to do it and also someone
who doesn't realize they can do it until
say midway through the movie now if
you're loyal theorists do you know that
right now is the best part of the
episode now's the part where I pull out
the evidence that I've been hiding away
to really drive home the connection
between these two tenuously linked
characters in order to totally blow your
mind
so get ready here it comes there is
nothing seriously I was looking all over
the place for more connections poring
through old Excalibur and x-force comics
looking to link Peter wisdom to this
incredible Twitter account but there's
not a whole
lot else there there's just a lot of
things that don't quite add up you see
the Peter wisdom from the comics is a
cynical chain-smoker with a hard edge
and flexible morals if you're a thrill
as Twitter posts Peter W IRL is just a
mild-mannered beekeeper who strongly
against using drugs he hates swearing
and is easily fooled by basic photoshop
skills when Peter wisdom in the comics
joins the Excalibur team he's a swing
and single and dedicates a lot of his
time to having a fling with Kitty Pryde
shadowcats well Peter w claims to be
happily married to a woman named Susan
who if you read between the lines and
the tweets appears to be cheating on him
that's just a mini theory though sure in
the Ultimate Comics universe Peter
wisdoms power is derived from a serum
much like Deadpool's power from the
first movie so maybe that's where things
are headed there but honestly Peter W is
fairly different in almost every single
way which makes me think that something
is clearly wrong here and that's when it
hit me Peter W is a nobody with no
special powers he is exactly what the
trailer is selling mass because Deadpool
is playing a much bigger joke and it's
on us the theorists of the Internet
Deadpool execs know exactly how much
trailers get extensively scanned and
analyzed these days by rabid fanboys
looking to expose the hidden secrets
before the movie gets released just look
at my nearly 16 minute long video from
just a few weeks ago about the missing
infinity stone that spanned dozens of
movies and TV shows and trailers and
ultimately it amounted to nothing when
infinity war came out same with my last
Jedi predictions same thing for most of
our prediction theories quite honestly
what better meta Deadpool joke is there
in 2018 than to dangle a big juicy
question mark in front of our faces like
some average Joe gia so happens to share
a letter and a name with a character in
a similar story as the comics that the
directors are pulling from and then just
last Jedi it away peter's twitter
account here is just a litany of hidden
comics jokes peter w underscore 1974
well 1974 is the first year wolverine
graced the pages of a marvel comic in
just another reference to Deadpool's
best frenemies forever one of his pinned
tweets was of deadpool riding a tiger
with wings which is just a reference to
the classic rainbow deadpool me Peter's
wife Susan seems to be cheating on her
husband with her personal trainer named
Gus who may or may
not be a reference to minor x-men
character Gus Grimm the fact that the
team working on this movie has given out
enough information to know it's Peter W
but haven't actually revealed his full
name when they've exposed pretty much
every other character it's almost as if
Deadpool is inviting us to fall into his
trap
to make our own theory go ahead and let
peter w reflect whatever you want him to
be because when he ultimately ends up
being nobody like we told you in the
trailer it'll make it all the funnier
Peter W is just an absolutely average
human being with nothing special to
offer the team outside of his unending
optimism it's the ultimate Deadpool joke
purposely leading us in one direction
through the trailers and other online
marketing tool only to pull the rug out
from under us for the laughs later
Deadpool tends to operate Peters likely
to get himself horrific ly killed in the
first real dangerous situation he comes
across at which point I wouldn't be so
surprised if Deadpool turned to the
camera and said oh that didn't ruin your
fan theory well sorry Deadpool I hope I
didn't just ruin your punchline actually
I kind of hope it did cuz that would
mean that one of these prediction
theories was actually right for a change
but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and do me a favor and
actually send this video to at Peter W
underscore 1974 on Twitter make sure you
include me in that tweet at matpat GT
Peter W has apparently done interviews
in the past so maybe he'll respond or
react to this theory sometime before the
release of the movie which would be
incredible so if you could raise this to
his attention that would be amazing make
sure you hit that subscribe button that
you see on screen right now so that way
if he does respond you'll be the first
to know if we do feature it on the
channel and if you've missed my last
Deadpool episodes well then click the
boxes you see on screen the one to the
left is how Deadpool is secretly Ernest
Hemmingway which is undoubtedly one of
my most absurd theories of all time and
the one to the right is how you could
kill Deadpool should be a lot of fun
[Music]